[Music]
hey what's up everybody
before we get started with this video I
just want to remind everybody that today
is the very last day that you can enter
our giveaway I'm giving away a speaker
system and all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel hit the like
button and comment below with your
favorite superhero that can be from
Marvel from DC from anywhere it could
even be Goku for those of you that have
been asking yes it does help your
chances to comment on all other videos
I'm going to be randomly selecting a
video and then randomly selecting a
comment I'm only going to select a
comment from videos that I released
after I announced the giveaway nothing
before if you haven't seen Avengers
infinity war yet what are you doing it's
been out forever now but really it's an
amazing movie and you need to go see it
like ASAP
and besides that spoiler alert because
I'm gonna talk about some stuff that
happened so after the movie came out a
lot of the fans were blaming star-lord
for the Avengers losing to Thanos in the
movie because he kept them from getting
the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos so
ultimately the fanbase is blaming
star-lord for Thanos wiping out half of
the universe a lot of you asked me about
this and I ended up doing a video on it
and you can catch that video in the link
above and it basically describes how
it's not star Lord's fault this was all
part of dr. Strange's plan it was part
of the one scenario where they win and
it went exactly as it was supposed to it
wasn't his fault but there have recently
been some new developments it turns out
that if you do in fact think into star
Lords fault then you also think it's
Thor's fault
with so many fans jumping to this
conclusion of blaming star-lord
directors Joe and Anthony Russo weighed
in on the subject here's what Joe and
Anthony Russo had to say on star-lord
punching Thanos in the face and
ultimately ruining the Avengers getting
the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos
Anthony Russo said
Thor also let his emotions get the
better of him Thor could have killed
Thanos more quickly than he tried to
with the axe he showed up and he took a
moment because of his anger because of
his motivation to tell Thanos that he
told them he would die and finish him
off in a very deliberate way
Thor sort of got lost in his emotions in
a similar way as star-lord and could
also have been responsible for Thanos
Vin Joe added they make very human
choices I think if you learn anything
from narrative is to put yourself inside
the POV of someone or the character
itself you should be able to empathize
with them understand the choices that
they make and what the Russo brothers
are saying is true they're trying to
make us feel for the characters they're
trying to make us feel what they feel
Thor could have easily killed Thanos at
the end he throws Stormbreaker
right into thin OSes chest purposefully
might I add to make him suffer he
doesn't want to grant him a quick death
he wants him to die slowly and he wants
to talk to him before he kills him when
Thor lands on the ground in front of
Thanos he stares at him as he walks
towards him and he takes his time when
he walks towards him walking like a big
shot might I add then he grabs him by
the back of the head
looks him in the eye and says I told you
you die for that this is him of course
referring to Thanos killing Heimdall and
then he looks him in the eye again
staring him down and digs the hammer
even deeper into Thanos his chest and in
that scene as he digs the hammer in his
chest and Thanos screams out of pain you
could see Thor's face and how much the
anger still inside of him but how much
he enjoys getting his revenge for his
brother Loki and for Heimdall and all
the Asgardians that danos killed and
then Thanos begins to grumble a little
bit and Thor lets him talk he wants to
hear what he has to say because he
thinks he's going to admit some sort of
defeat but then Thanos gives us his
famous one-liner and says you should
have gone for the head and then BAM
snaps his fingers and half of the
universe is erased from existence and
Thor could have stopped him Thor had a
good 30 seconds to smash that hammer
into his face but he doesn't because he
lets his emotions get the best of them
because they're trying to portray him as
a real person so according to the Russo
brothers and logic really if you're
gonna blame star-lord you have to blame
Thor too but again this is all
irrelevant because everything went
exactly as it was supposed to go Doctor
Strange went forward in time in Sawle
over 14mm
in different scenarios in which they
only won one and that is the scenario
that is happening at the end of infinity
war we know this because at the very end
after the snap as dr. strange is being
wiped away from existence he tells Tony
that this was the only way that means
things are still going according to plan
for that one scenario in which the
Avengers beat Thanos well that's it for
this video I hope it further clarifies
to you that it wasn't really star Lords
fault it wasn't Thor's fault it was all
supposed to happen
but regardless let me know what you
think do you still think it's star Lords
fault and Thor's fault or are you
convinced that this is all according to
dr. Strange's plan and the scenario in
which they actually defeat Thanos let me
know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this video hit that like button
please and also again be sure to
subscribe to stay up-to-date on infinity
war avengers for marvel and to be
entered in our giveaway again today's
the last day thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]